donald trump der ehemalige us-präsident
hat vor einigen wochen seine eigene
social media plattform gegründet
usocial die app sieht ähnlich aus wie
twitter nur dass keine tweets geteilt
werden sondern schuf übersetzt
wahrheiten was ist jetzt daraus geworden
zum einen ein ziemlicher flop wegen
technischer probleme sind aktuell über
eine million nutzer innen auf einer
warteliste zum anderen die plattform ist
jetzt schon voller verschwörungstheorien
und falsch nachrichten zb zum ukraine
krieg wieso uns dass trotzdem
interessieren sollte trans unternehmen
will auch in streaming geschäft
einsteigen schon jetzt hat trump viel
einfluss auf die politische meinung in
den usa mit seinem newsletter und mit
tv-auftritten erreicht er immer noch
millionen menschen hinzu kommt in
umfragen um eine mögliche
präsidentschafts 2024 führt trans
aktuell vor us präsident joe biden